what's going on reject nation Greg alla
here and I'm John Humphrey over here so
we just saw oh man we decide you're here
Sasson woo best movies summer easily
have fault
today's patron of the day shy not gonna
go out to Natalie Duran yeah look out
Natalie will do it before we wrap up
this video so we saw Kingsman last night
that review will be up on the 18th once
the embargo lifts watching mother
tomorrow man American assassin the first
like 30 to 40 minutes of this movie
maybe the first half oh yeah like the
first act the first act for sure pretty
pretty pretty good amount of like the
first half of act 2 I would say I was
pretty yeah I've said like a half first
half yeah it starts to lose me a little
I've lost me a little sooner than a loss
to the movie gripped me right off the
bat yeah that whole beach scene and
everything yeah this movies more violent
than the than I expected it to be
actually I mean even though they had
like a red band trailer I was surprised
by like well this is like really violent
this is a gritty realistic violence
right it's pretty disturbing actually
yeah they want you to feel the impact of
all those things and Dylan O'Brien I
mean if you guys just I know a lot of
people are excited for this film
primarily because of Dylan O'Brien
that's a big novel series that a lot of
people are invested in but it seems like
a lot of people what they're mainly
gravitated towards is Dylan O'Brien so
that's your main concern I'm here to
assure you Dylan O'Brien rocks this role
he's not just a physical performance
with the emotional performance
especially absolutely nails it and it
makes me wish this movie was better so
it could be guaranteed a sequel because
this guy deserves a really good
franchise she's a damn good actor I like
him a lot as this Mitch character is a
fantastic actor and I wish this movie
was better because I would like to see
this character more in a better movie
yeah I feel like the one thing that you
or at least I could truly recommend
about this movie is the heart and soul
of this what little heart and soul
[Laughter]
he feels like a lived-in character and
he sells both the trauma and he sells
you know the physical capability and you
know the the heightened instincts of an
American assassin and he also you know
he also brings the dental rhyme
personality and charm to the character
in case you guys haven't seen the
trailer I don't feel like I'm spoiling I
think it's a trailer this guy has he his
girlfriend gets killed on a beach trip
they're having one day and then it could
Simpson out of the spiraling path of
grief where he gets sent on revenge
he'd be a badass yeah that's to kill
every terrorist he could find exactly
then he eventually gets recruited by the
CIA and that was being put on a mission
that's the fascinating part of this
movie because the first 30 to 40 minutes
of this film is a character focus of
this Mitch guy and I really was invested
in that I like seeing the emotional
struggle he was having and then he gets
recruited by the CIA and it goes under
training with Michael Keaton's character
and Michael Keaton does a really good
job in this to me you would expect
nothing less than Michael Keaton he does
a really good job as well and it's the
cool the seem more like a badass type of
character role because he is badass yeah
and in terms of things Rick worth
recommending he is solid number two yeah
easily movie I mean he doesn't bring a
lot of personality and you believe him
to their chemistry together it's really
good - I like the mentorship
relationship that forms between the two
of them yeah that's one of the few
character relationships that actually
feels real and and the movie do I know a
couple other critics have said this
movie does shine most when they're
on-screen together yeah when they're
actually butting heads and exploring the
lifestyle yeah you know through that and
I think the reason why the first 30 or
40 minutes is interesting is because the
way the movies setting it up it has this
really cool focus of this guy who's
grieving over the loss of the woman he
loved and now he's becoming this like
violent weapon then as he gets recruited
to become an assassin it looks like it's
becoming a film that's gonna be an
exploration of why is he doing this is
this only for revenge is there more to
the cause than this what is his art
gonna be is he gonna be able to come to
terms with his trauma of the horrible
incident that happened that day on the
beach so it has a lot of great setting
up and exploration all the times I read
visit his traumas I thought was really
interesting yeah set up a lot of steaks
yes Regan emotional and vest
I thought it was going to be this
personal contained stores called
American assassins so I thought I was
gonna be a character study a blur Asia
guy who becomes an assassin and his
reasons as to why and what he becomes
along the journey how it affects him the
choices he has to move without a doubt
at least halfway through the movie it
just stops Oh
wrote actions yeah you know it econ it
becomes a really generic rather dull
spiders the most bored I've been in a
movie theater in a little while anyway
it stops focusing on all the things that
made the movie interesting yeah yeah
yeah and then it just becomes the
problem is that it swaps you know diving
into an assassin character and it's a
swap set out for you know going on
another crazy mission just a mission and
stop a nuclear bomb yeah and nothing
lasts any amount of time in this movie
so it's like he just starts training and
then they're like up your first mission
and here we go on to a plot that isn't
as interesting as anything else that
came in the set up there time lapses are
kind of confusing because sometimes I
put a text at the bottom says like
eighteen months later so you know how
much time has passed and other times
like he goes to training and the reason
the CIA recruits him is because they see
how much she's learn on his own you know
he's an MMA classes he's basically
infiltrating terrorist cells like just
yeah at home on the night yeah that's
fascinating but then I thought about
later I'm like the movie never takes
time to explain where this kid learned
how to do all these things yeah we don't
see him pick up halfway like most of the
skills he actively uses in the film like
he goes to camp with with Michael Keaton
yeah and the rest of it is like you went
through this traumatic experience picked
up a bunch of desirable qualities that
make you a great assassin and we don't
get to explore to see any of that now
get to see things work out for this guy
because apparently his heightened
instincts are just that good
you see I think this movie could have
been better if they just stuck to the
personal vibes it was having the trailer
reveals the Taylor Kitsch is in this
movie and Taylor Kitsch is character
apparently is revealed I think in the
second trailer he's a former student of
Michael Keaton's
yeah and now he's you know turned bad
guy I'm like okay we just could be Mitch
yeah me exactly I thought the movie was
going that fat okay you got two choices
of generic movies you can get one
generic movie which is what American
assassin gave us which was this boring
mission that I could care less basically
just any other Doomsday's in there yeah
then I thought like I would have
preferred the other generic tale of how
they the film was focusing on Michael
Keaton and Dylan O'Brien and then
Michael Keaton has this former student
who is similar to Dylan O'Brien's guy he
kind of worries about training Dylan
O'Brien because he sees that the last
guy who had an attitude like dental
Brian turned into a bad guy and the
movie just doesn't like take advantage
of that it's like what somehow nobody
has to dwell upon what might have led to
this yeah like Michael Keaton doesn't
have to dwell upon well did I build this
thing am i accountable in some way they
set up this whole thing that could have
been interesting and then it's just I
don't know he's just a bad guy and we
just gotta stop I could feel like it
probably in the book it's paced on it's
probably all there yeah I feel like in
the movies it's not felt or a strongly
present it's like it's there's
expositional dialogue to lead to that
but it's not felt and that's the main
gripe I have with that specific
storyline this really felt like they're
trying to swing broad this feels like
the Hollywood version of that book that
that probably missed a lot of the tonin
spirit the one thing I thought was kind
of like and so what angered me about
this film there's a training scene where
we're Michael Keaton's teaching his
recruits how to kind of guys the road
and he's saying like here's something
you in the movies that's only in the
movies here's how you're supposed to do
it that's only in the movies there's so
much crap that happens during the
mission part that's just so unrealistic
I'm like well that's the movie do that
become the thing we were saying it's not
this movie has just one Universal arc
where it starts out gritty and
unsettling and real cuz like the
beginning of the movie is attacked
happen and so like that's really jarring
to watch especially the way they film it
and then over the course the movie just
gets less and less realistic and like
rules of physics stop mattering the
film's better when it was focusing
solely on the
shanell journey in the psychological
journey dylan o'brien and the
relationship he was forming with Michael
Keaton and then halfway through it's
like you got so many characters and all
these things and it's like just go back
to Dylan O'Brien already interesting guy
in the movie people want to spend much
time on any of the carriage now make any
of them interest ya see ya after a while
you're like either flesh somebody out or
make our leads more interesting or
something like something do something
interesting
what's especially upsetting was doing
its movie just wraps up by the end yeah
cuz by the time it was boy anything
because there's nothing to spoil there's
no arc for this guy there's no art for
anybody but I'm like you had clear
setups for a very specific arc that
could have been felt even if we saw it
coming but there's nothing oh by the end
the only are the only archive found in
this entire movie was like maybe towards
the end with Michael Keaton being a
little bit like yeah maybe I should take
a break most anybody changed over the
Christmas it's weird like it calls the
title into question because you have
American assassin yeah have at least
three key characters that all fit that
description and you walk out of the
movie with no insight on any of them no
it's not yeah it's gonna give it that
title I give it make it an exploration
tale of being an assassin or just give
us a generic CIA oh yeah you should've
just called this a bunch of ass ass yeah
because that's a bit more accurate other
than the fact that it's probably really
awkward watching this movie if you're a
Muslim it's weird to me because Dylan
O'Brien is easily the best part of this
whole film a fantastic woman but in
terms of like some writing and some
action stuff I was also like why does
this guy seem like he just gets hit a
few times this movie didn't take time to
establish if he has any prior training
before his girlfriend got a girlfriend
Gus Keaton gets killed and there's an 18
month period I don't think he just
started hitting the gym day one he's
been shot and he has to yeah gotta get
revenge it's gonna work out every day
and learn every inch of the Koran use
like an cyclopædia college of Islam so
it would bother me when I when I'm like
doesn't seem like this guy's ever
really in danger of being oh yeah he's
not treated at all like he's a rookie
when I'm like the guys rookie man and
they keep making a point of going like
ah you know when the chips are down he
makes his own
it's calls and he goes and does it that
just always kind of works out yeah cuz
the movies setting it up like he has
potential to be more but from what the
movie gave us I'm like it looks like he
trained for about a month and they've
got put on him
one of the biggest missions he could
have been ever put on yeah Marty does
great man he does great and this movie
is full of people doing that same thing
it's like this movies about a team
trying to get stuff done you know trying
to do these covert counter-terror
operations and yet nobody ever seems
like they want to work together or ever
on the same page like every major
characters making their own decisions
and being like well if you don't agree
with me I don't care no one's working
together yeah I just feel this
especially by the finale the film just
gets too ambitious it just tries to
become bigger than what it needed to be
it was like know you could've just made
it's a really contain and bypass story
where you got Dylan O'Brien's main
character main supporting characters
Michael Keaton in the villain Taylor
Kitsch that's all you have to make it
yeah it could have been that simple you
really they missed out on the born
market I feel like they were trying to
target with this cuz they had all the
pieces they needed they could have
everything in this movie could have come
together to make the movie you wanted
and it could have been but yeah this is
a road CIA thriller by the end of it
yeah if I had to give this a rating I
would I would say half-awake a guy next
to me fell asleep we went to an
afternoon show started snoring
I would give this movie 18 months hey
that's all the time it takes to learn
all of his line all the fighting and all
the good guys and become you know laser
accurately become the best assassin in
the world and look I mean he's got
glasses amorita
in the eighth and in that 18 months
that's not CIA training that is all
self-taught YouTube you can learn a lot
you can learn a lot on YouTube so what
did you guys think of American assassin
did you love it comment below and let us
know how dumb we are for not for not
liking me you really anticipated oh and
before this video is done Natalie Duran
panzram of the day shout out normally we
do our shout outs on the reaction videos
but she wanted it for this one because
she's a huge fan of dylan o'brien she's
from Ireland she's awesome she's really
pretty she's really friendly really
knowledgeable works with a lot of
elderly people she has a way more
important job than us and she loves
Dylan O'Brien Greg I love me some didn't
know Brian he's a good not that one do
you know any of his relatives you know
do his relatives Natalie oh your dentist
let me do my warm up accent here Ireland
ox oxen periwinkle blue it says in
snatch it one day when we go to all your
Lind yeah we're going to visit to you
together we're gonna have a good time
we're gonna we were not Colin Farrell
your ass we're gonna ace off that one
video he released a black girl like you
complaining about why YouTube odds don't
play on our videos anymore
comments like this screws us over
you stay friendly you stay pretty being
pretty I've said this to you before is
the most important asset that you could
ever have tell you look not how you
feeling it's never about what you think
and what you feel especially as an Irish
woman in Ireland if anyone knows Irish
culture it's us Californian from my
understanding Conor McGregor would only
date you if you are beautiful wouldn't
care who you are on the inside so keep
those looks up your personality
probably fourth important on the list
yeah I mean you don't really need one
yeah just he'll look you know it's like
extra credit body back of the body then
your personality anterior-posterior yeah
no we're just kidding Natalie thanks for
being part of our patreon and thanks to
fajn our channel we really are a sweet
girl we love talking with you well I
love talking you haven't talked with her
I love talking I'm sorry that you're
Irish MMA fighter got destroyed by our
American boxer that's right who we were
all totally rooting for me yeah yeah
everyone in America it's totally nobody
nobody rooting for McGregor I did you
hear the people at the fight everyone
was cheering for me when I'm playing
yeah this is what we expected to happen
there was no tension all right well you
guys can subscribe you the real rejects
please click that notification bell
followed at John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and go check out our patreon
become a patron objected a lot of great
stuff over there my friends